لقد حذرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من تفشي
محتمل الاوبئه فور وصوله الى حلب قال
المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
اطحنهم
ان فريقه لمنظمه الذي سافر معه احضر 35
طولنا من مواد الاغاثه واضاف الى طائره
اخرى تحمل 30 طن من معدات طبيه ستصل خلال
الايام المقبله
سنواصل دعمكم ايضا في جلب مزيد من امدادات
الطوارئ هذا اول شيء اعتقد انه ستكون هناك
شحنه اخرى غدا باكثر من 30 طن متريا وبعد
ذلك سنواصل تقديم الدعم لتوفير امدادات
الطوارئ وخاصه الضروريه منها والذي تعتبر
مهمه للتعامل مع الصدمات القويه للمتضررين
من الزلزال ولكن ليس هذا فقط فنحن قلقون
من التاثيرات اللاحقه للزلزال ايضا لان
امدادات المياه قد تاثرت وتاثرت الخدمات
الاخرى وتعرض الناس لامراض منقوله جوا
ومشاكل الصحيه اخرى وخاصه امراض الصحه
العقليه لذا سنعمل معا لمعالجه تاثير هذا
الزلزال ولن نركز فقط على خدمه الطوارئ